mon corps se recroquevait sur lui-même
j'avais la tête qui rentrait dans les
épaules et
des larmes commençaient à couler sur mon
visage rouge de honte
c'est toujours la même chose c'était
toujours la même histoire au collège en
cours de français quand il fallait
passer au tableau réciter une poésie ou
pire jouer une pièce de théâtre parce
que là il fallait incarner un personnage
il fallait être à l'aise et moi j'étais
pas du tout à l'aise
j'ai une enfance
vraiment heureuse mais ce moment là pour
moi c'était la pire chose qui pouvait
arriver dans ma vie d'enfant
c'était ma plus grosse angoisse je
savais qu'à un moment donné dans l'année
au collège en cours de français j'allais
devoir passer au tableau et parler
devant des gens
j'allais être à la merci de tous les
regards
et pendant quelques instants j'allais
être au centre de l'attention de toute
la pièce la ma professeur de français
allait noter ma prestation tous les
autres élèves allaient pouvoir
m'observer ils allaient me scruter de de
ma coiffure à mes chaussures en passant
par mes vêtements comment je suis
habillé ma silhouette ils allaient tout
voir tout que je suis pas à l'aise je
sais pas quoi faire de mes mains alors
ce que je faisais moi c'est que je les
mettais dans mes poches et j'avais un
peu ce réflexe de d'essayer de me faire
tout petit comme si c'était la meilleure
solution pour éviter les les éventuels
critiques ou peut-être esquiver le
jugement ou peut-être si vraiment
j'arrive à me faire le plus petit
possible ils allaient plus me voir
à ce moment là
j'allais plus pouvoir me cacher derrière
personne j'allais plus pouvoir être sur
mon bureau tranquillement derrière le
dos d'un camarade quand la prof me donne
la parole j'allaite comme tout nu sans
défense
au tableau devant une dizaine de paires
à ce moment-là quand la professeur
prononçait mon nom parce que c'était à
mon tour d'aller au tableau
j'espère qu'une seule chose j'avais
qu'un seul souhait c'était de
disparaître de la surface de la terre de
plus exister tellement ça m'angoissait
j'y pensais depuis la veille et même le
premier jour de la rentrée quand on
avait le premier jour de cours de
français je savais que ça allait arriver
qu'à un moment donné j'allais devoir
parler devant des gens
alors à ce moment-là quand j'étais au
tableau
j'espérais secrètement que
la sonnerie retentisse et que la
professeure nous dise que
finalement on va attendre la prochaine
heure de cours pour continuer et comme
ça ça allait me laisser un peu plus de
temps pour me préparer et peut-être que
si j'avais plus de temps pour me
préparer le jour J j'allais être plus à
l'aise et ça se passait jamais comme ça
j'avais beau avoir beaucoup plus de
temps pour me préparer le jour J j'étais
toujours en stress
ou peut-être que pour je ne sais quelle
raison la professeur nous dit que cette
année la poésie et le théâtre c'est plus
au programme
mais ça non plus
alors la seule solution qui me restait
une fois que j'avais plus d'échappatoire
que j'étais au tableau et que je devais
commencer à réciter ma poésie ou jouer
ma pièce de théâtre la seule option qui
me restait c'était de pleurer de me
mettre dans tous mes états de fondre en
larmes
comme ça je pensais inconsciemment
attendrir ma professeur lui faire pitié
pour qu'elle me dise
tu sais quoi Paolo va te rasseoir c'est
pas grave je sais que pour toi parler en
public c'est un exercice difficile tu es
un enfant plutôt timide réservé je vois
que tu es pas bien c'est pas grave
rassis toi sache tes larmes c'est pas
grave
ça non plus ça n'est jamais arrivé au
contraire elle gardait un visage très
froid et en me regardant elle me disait
continue
elle me laissait
au tableau tout seul tout transpirant en
train de pleurer avec vraiment un regard
désespéré elle me laissait au tableau
jusqu'à ce que le dernier mot du poème
sorte de ma bouche
je vous épargne les détails de la salle
de classe parce que forcément à cet
âge-là et surtout en groupe les enfants
sont très méchants donc ça n'arrange pas
la situation
une fois que j'avais terminé ma poésie
ou ma pièce de théâtre je me renseignais
à ma place je regardais la professeure
et je me disais à quel point je la
détesté je l'ai haïssais
est-ce qu'elle est vraiment humaine
pourquoi elle a pas vu
à quel point ça me touchait que cet
exercice c'était difficile pour moi ça
se voyait pourquoi elle m'a pas dit de
retourner à ma place
j'en suis même arrivé à un moment à me
dire que en fait elle était sadique et
qu'elle éprouvait un réel plaisir à voir
des enfants de 11 ans souffrir
en fait cette année là
elle m'a enseigné une leçon qu'elle
allait me suivre toute ma vie et qui de
toute ma scolarité pour être franc avec
vous c'est la seule leçon dont je me
souviens encore parce que en
mathématiques le théorème de Pythagore
pour être honnête je serai pas vous le
refaire aujourd'hui et pour être encore
plus honnête je sais même plus à quoi il
sert
les conjugaisons des verbes en espagnol
j'ai tout oublié mais ce qu'elle a voulu
me faire comprendre ce jour là
c'est que dans la vie je devais
affronter mes problèmes plutôt que de
les fuir
et mon problème moi du plus loin que je
peux me souvenir c'est que j'ai toujours
été
assez mal à l'aise dans les situations
avec les gens dans les situations
sociales j'ai toujours eu peur du regard
des gens des autres peur de leur
jugement des pensées négatives qui
pouvaient avoir à mon égard
et
et de parler en public n'en parlons même
pas
et
[Musique]
ça c'est difficile à comprendre pour un
enfant de 11 ans mais en m'obligeant à
faire face à mon problème
on obligeant à affronter mon problème
elle a évité que ce phénomène s'aggrave
avec les années parce que les années
suivantes en cours de français quand il
fallait redresser une poésie ou jouer
une pièce de théâtre j'étais pas devenu
un acteur hors pair mais au moins je
réussissais à terminer la poésie sans
bégayer sans pleurer j'étais pas le plus
à l'aise mais un petit peu plus que les
fois précédentes
en allant affronter mon problème plutôt
que de le fuir à chaque occasion
elle m'a aidé en quelque sorte à
m'habituer à cette situation qui me
terrifiait c'est un peu comme quand tu
regardes un film d'horreur la première
fois quand arrive le moment qui fait le
plus peur tu vas sursauter et ton cœur
va battre très vite pendant les 5
minutes qui suivent la deuxième fois
toujours ce même moment tu vas sursauter
mais tu vas très vite te remettre de tes
émotions et la troisième fois parce que
tu sais à quoi t'attendre ça va plus
rien faire
et ce phénomène là
je les fais mieux
parce que j'ai vu à quel point il a été
efficace avec l'exercice de la poésie
je savais que si je voulais grandir et
m'améliorer dans les situations qui me
posaient des difficultés à cause de mon
introversion je devais partir en guerre
contre ces problèmes de timide alors à
chaque fois qu'il y avait une situation
qui me faisait peur à ce niveau-là
j'allais l'affronter
par exemple en 2019 je tombe sur la
chaîne Youtube d'un Américain qui fait
des vidéos qui il a lancé une série qui
s'appelle la thérapie du rejet c'est à
dire que tous les jours il allait dehors
pour demander des choses très gênantes
et très bizarre à des gens
par exemple il allait un jour il a fait
ça pendant 100 jours un jour il est allé
sonner chez des gens pour demander s'il
pouvait juste planter une fleur dans
leur jardin ça paraît bête mais
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait
naturellement il allait dans la rue pour
demander des compliments à des inconnus
il allait dans un salon de toilettage
pour chien pour demander s'il pouvait se
faire couper les cheveux et moi en
regardant ça j'avais vraiment la boule
au ventre je ressentais la gêne à
travers mon écran
et je me suis mis à sa place j'ai essayé
de me mettre à sa place
et je me sentais vraiment pas bien
parce que j'imaginais ce que lui pouvait
vivre il pouvait voir en direct le
jugement dans les yeux des gens en face
de lui il pouvait penser qu'il était
bizarre que c'était un fou qu'il était
pas fait pour vivre en société un tas de
choses négatives et en mettant à sa
place j'avais très peur et j'étais pas à
l'aise avec ce sentiment de peur je
voulais m'en débarrasser alors je me
suis dit je vais faire la même chose
pendant 30 jours pareil je suis sorti de
chez moi et tous les jours j'allais
demander quelque chose de très bizarre à
des gens
j'ai défié des inconnus sur un 100
mètres dans la rue j'ai je suis allé
chez Burger King et j'ai demandé à un
gars qui mangeait tranquillement si je
pouvais croquer dans dans son burger et
ça se voyait qu'il avait pas très envie
mais je crois qu'il était très gentil du
coup il m'a laissé un morceau
et tout ça au final on allant affronter
mon problème je me suis rendu compte de
deux choses soit ça crée des situations
à inattendues et qui était plutôt drôle
qui crée des choses
qui crée des situations intéressantes ou
alors quand je me faisais rejeter bien
sûr que ça ça faisait pas du bien
j'étais très mal à l'aise sur le moment
mais je suis pas mort
et
c'est ça qui faut retenir c'est que j'ai
affronté ce problème là
et au final ben je me rends compte que
j'avais pas avoir peur de ça
récemment j'apprends le mandarin tout
seul chez moi et je sais que la
meilleure méthode pour progresser et
pour m'amuser en même temps c'est
d'aller parler au chinois que je croise
tous les jours dans la rue dans ma ville
mais encore une fois je me trouvais des
excuses un tas d'excuses en me disant
que peut-être que ça se fait pas dans
leur culture ou peut-être qu'ils
allaient croire que je me moque d'eux ou
peut-être que ils allaient se moquer de
moi parce que mon chinois n'est pas
assez bon
et pareil c'était encore un problème je
devais l'affronter ça me faisait peur je
devrais l'affronter alors j'ai pris mon
courage à deux mains et pendant une
certaine période j'allais commander mes
bubble teen chinois quand je voyais des
Chinois dans la rue j'allais leur parler
et leur taper la discute et au final
encore une fois on affrontant mon
problème je me suis rendu compte que
ils étaient tous gentils et très patient
et que c'était même je pense la
meilleure méthode pour apprendre une
langue étrangère et la plus gratifiante
il y a 10 minutes
juste penser à l'idée de parler devant
une audience plus nombreuse qu'une salle
de classe
j'avais la trouille là je suis un peu
plus de la moitié de ma conférence et
j'ai toujours pas pleuré donc
je pense que c'est pas mal
fuir ces problèmes
fuir ces problèmes ça nous rend serein
jusqu'au moment où on les rencontre
mais les affronter
c'est la meilleure façon d'être serein à
chaque fois qu'on les recroise
en faisant ça on est tranquille pour
tout le reste de sa vie
heureusement que ma professeur de
français en sixième c'est pas laisser
attendrir par mes larmes de crocodiles
parce que si la première fois elle
m'avait dit de me rasoir au lieu de
m'obliger à continuer elle me rend
handicapée à vie
il y a plein de choses
il y a plein d'expérience que j'aurais
pas pu vivre dans ma vie il y a plein de
choses que j'aurais pas pu faire
et surtout
j'aurais jamais eu le courage de venir
ici aujourd'hui
donc merci à elle et merci à vous
[Applaudissements]